at first glance it looks like a Gangland
killing or perhaps a political
assassination
two trucks of men mostly in plain
clothes pull up next to their victim and
shoot him
the man is a 40 year old father of two
he lives just around the corner and had
stopped by to catch up with a friend
Iranian authorities say a group of
unknown gunmen are responsible but what
these killers didn't know is that their
actions were being recorded
we've broken down this vital evidence to
show you what really happened
in Iran's Kurdistan province the city is
a commercial hub not far from the border
with Iraq
its Northwest periphery is a quiet part
of town which is mostly residential it's
where motileb Saeed Peru lived and where
he found himself on the afternoon of
October 27th
the date on the recording reflects the
Persian calendar
4 15 PM motoleb is standing by his car
seemingly checking his phone when he
sees something that makes him frightened
the white truck arrives at the scene
it's a Toyota Hilux which experts tell
us is commonly used by Iran's feared
revolutionary guard or irgc as he
scrambles to get inside his car we see
the intimidation of mottleleb play out
in real time a man in the back of the
truck aims his weapon at mottola but
doesn't fire
two others in plain clothes jump out and
begin to crowd his car
another vehicle connected to the regime
a Toyota Land Cruiser is now there too
the men in the back give us important
Clues experts tell us that their helmets
uniforms and weapons indicate that this
is a mix of irgc and its militia the
besiege this seems to confirm that the
men in the white truck are also regime
forces there are now at least 10 of them
there
one smashes motileb's car
he begins to drive away but the men
aren't finished yet one shoots his
weapon through the driver's window and
another through the back
those in the second truck seem surprised
they stand up to get a better look at
what's happened
Leb manages the 240 meter drive back to
his home but his wounds are serious
he's pulled from the car by his
neighbors and soon dies from his
injuries his family are devastated
I don't know what to say I was standing
and then I had to sit down on the sofa
I was speechless I did not know what to
do I had no joy anymore
Iran before moving to Sweden they were
very close
[Music]
was very down to earth he was very
sociable serious and kind
yeah
people were fond of him he was
open-minded
and then I'll
he was an integral part of the family in
good and bad times
the attackers came
they were not on order to deliberately
kill motileb and other footage from the
incident seems to support this further
up the road bystanders can be seen
running away while one of the men chases
after them
and after motilev drives off the group
begins to attack another vehicle
the Iranian regime has been known to
Target individuals they believe to be
connected to the Kurdish separatist
movement but the family we've spoken to
outside of Iran as well as other sources
say motileb was not politically active
they also said he had not been involved
in the current protests
The Killing however occurred the day
after there were demonstrations across
the country to Mark the 40th Day after
Masa amini's death in police custody
similar trucks to those we saw on the
CCTV can be seen firing at civilians in
Barnet
I can assume that they have been
deployed to this neighborhood mostly
because there was some kind of the
politics in the days before they have
sent these forces to to to to terrorize
the neighborhood to send a message that
we are going to punish you Iranian
authorities blame unknown armed
individuals for motileb's death
but the CCTV evidence suggests that the
men are linked to the regime this
pattern of violence is something we've
seen across Iran as unrest continues in
Kurdish areas it's getting worse rights
groups say that dozens of people have
been killed since November 15.
but mortaleb's grieving family are left
with one question why was he killed
was a man in a wrong place in a wrong
time as you know became the target of
the brutality of the irdc and the
besiege who come to this neighborhood to
terrorize people